bienvenidos ahora vamos a trabajar con
una masa en un plano inclinado vamos a
dibujar nuestro plano
inclinado como una superficie de hielo
con una pendiente y es de hielo porque
todavía no queremos trabajar con ningún
tipo de fricción aquí y también vamos a
tener encima de esta superficie un
bloque también de hielo para contar que
no tenemos ningún tipo de
fricción me quedó muy bien lo vuelvo a
dibujar
y tenemos eh que este bloque está en un
plano inclinado como lo pueden ver y
tiene una masa de 10
kg ahora también vamos a a establecer
por facilidad del cálculo eh que la
aceleración de la gravedad que es de
9.8 m sobre segundo al cuadrado vamos a
aproximar la en nuestros cálculos a 10 m
por segundo al cuadrado para que lo
tomen en cuenta así vamos a estar
trabajando en estos
videos entonces Eh bueno tenemos
este bloque que se va a mover ustedes
podrán intuir que este bloque se va a
resbalar hacia
acá y entonces Bueno qué va a ocurrir
ustedes Bueno como les dije se podran
imaginar que este bloque va a estar
deslizándose en esta
dirección y Queremos saber qué tanto se
va a acelerar en esta dirección vamos a
calcularlo Ya sabemos qué ocurriría si
no hubiera esta superficie si
estuviéramos en un bloque plano y
e en este caso Perdón en un bloque plano
no si tuviéramos este peso y lo
dejáramos caer sin ningún obstáculo e en
Entre él y el suelo y bueno podríamos
calcular eh la aceleración que sería la
de la aceleración de la gravedad de 10 m
por segundo cuadrado Pero bueno en este
caso del problema Qué es lo que está
ocurriendo Cuáles son las fuerzas que
están actuando aquí vamos a hacer lo
mismo que hemos hecho en los últimos
videos y es descomponer los vectores
veremos Cómo esto se comportan en las
diferentes direcciones Cuál es la fuerza
que jala hacia abajo esta mása
bueno es la fuerza de gravedad Cuál es
la magnitud de la fuerza de gravedad
vamos a
dibujar la gravedad que es está jalando
esta masa hacia abajo Ay Dios es hacia
abajo y esta fuerza de gravedad voy a
borrar esta parte que no que me quedó
Chueca y esta fuerza
Eh bueno tenemos con nuestra fórmula
fuerza igual a masa por
aceleración fuerza igual a masa por
aceleración sería igual a la masa de 10
kg por la aceleración de 10 m por
segundo cuadrado que sería igual o bueno
aproximadamente igual a 100
New entonces la fuerza de
gravedad sería 100 N también podemos
decir que su peso es de 100
New pero esta sería la fuerza de
gravedad esta fuerza hacia abajo
nosotros queremos saber qué tanto se
acelera en esta dirección diagonal qué
tanto se acelera en esta dirección y
además eh Cuando vemos la fricción
veremos qué tanto de esta fuerza de
gravedad estará O cuál será su
componente que estará Empujando la
superficie hacia abajo pues ya cuando
trabajamos con la fricción esto es
importante en términos de qué tanto se
estará oprimiendo sobre la superficie
lo que vamos a hacer es descomponer este
vector fuerza en sus dos elementos Uno
de ellos es la Normal o perpendicular al
plano este es perpendicular a este plano
entonces va a ir más o menos por
acá y esta le vamos a llamar aunque no
me acuerdo cuál es su
denominación oficial Vamos a ponerle
fuerza normal y es la que está eh hacia
dentro de este plano o es perpendicular
a este plano donde se está resbalando
nuestro
objeto y bueno vamos a ver el otro
componente que es aquel que es paralelo
al plano es el componente del vector
gravitacional que podríamos dibujar
sobre esta superficie pero vamos a
dibujar aquí encima de nuestro triángulo
bueno para formar un triángulo lo voy a
dibujar en
verde y este es paralelo a la ie
entonces va a ir por acá y voy a
extender mi vector de
gravedad de la fuerza de gravedad para
armar este
triángulo entonces Bueno aquí tenemos
nuestro vector de gravedad que va a ser
hacia abajo Nuestra
fuerza
Ah normal que va hacia acá perpendicular
al plano quiere decir que es tiene un
ángulo de 90 gr con respecto a este
plano y esta fuerza de componente
gravitacional que le vamos a poner fp
que es este fuerza paralela al plano
fp y bueno entonces queremos calcular lo
que es la fuerza normal y la fuerza
paralela para calcular estas
fuerzas tenemos que encontrar Cuál es el
ángulo Alfa en en este caso el ángulo
Alfa que nos interesa voy a dibujar es
este ángulo el que nos interesa saber
para poder conocer estos valores y bueno
resulta que este ángulo Alfa y Se los
voy a explicar aquí mismo es el mismo
ángulo que que tenemos
aquí y recordamos o les Bueno les hago
patente que también aquí tenemos un
ángulo recto o un ángulo de 90 gr
entonces Bueno cómo es que este ángulo
Alfa es igual a este bueno Y aunque
puedo saturar el dibujo bueno Se los voy
a explicar si ustedes ven este plano y
dibujá hubiéramos Cuántos grados hay en
esta curva o en esta parte de este plano
pues es la mitad de un círculo entonces
tendríamos 180 gr por lo que este ángulo
Alfa eh sería igual a Bueno aquí tenemos
un ángulo recto que es bueno perdón
vamos a comenzar contamos que ese total
todo esto Son 180
grados a estos 180 grados le
quitamos 90 gr voy a borrar un poco esto
un
momento Son 180 gr menos los 90 gr que
tenemos en este ángulo
recto y
además voy a quitar el ángulo Alfa que
es este que me interesa
entonces Eh bueno 180 - 90 nos queda la
resta que es 90 -
Alfa y sabemos que este ángulo de
aquí más este
ángulo de acá que son 90
gr y este que es 90 - Alfa Bueno hacemos
la resta aquí son 90 gr eh tenemos que
este ángulo de acá será 90 men Alfa este
ángulo de aquí si aquí tenemos Alfa y un
ángulo de 90 gr - 90 gr menos Alfa Bueno
vamos a tener que este ángulo es el
mismo que este A lo mejor los confundí
un poco pero bueno Les recomiendo que
revisen las propiedades de los ángulos
internos de un triángulo Para que vean
que así es y ahora podemos hacer los
cálculos si yo les dijera Cuál es el
ángulo de este plano inclinado ustedes
podrían encontrar los componentes de la
fuerza de gravedad y el componente de la
fuerza
normal entonces Eh bueno vamos a hacerlo
digamos que este plano
inclinado tiene un
ángulo de 30 gr vamos a decir entonces
que a Alfa en este ejemplo es igual a 30
gr Cuál sería la fuerza que es paralela
a la dirección en la que está resbalando
esta fuerza paralela bueno conocemos la
hipotenusa que en este caso es la fuerza
de gravedad y Queremos saber el lado
opuesto de este ángulo entonces la
función trigonométrica que nos sirve es
la función seno Entonces ya para esto
bueno para este momento después de haber
visto todos los videos anteriores eso ya
debe ser muy familiar para ustedes
tenemos que la fuerza paralela entre la
fuerza de gravedad o lo que es lo mismo
cateto opuesto sobre cateto adyacente va
a ser igual al seno del ángulo en este
caso nuestro ángulo es de 30 gr si
despejamos la fuerza paralela Tendremos
que es igual a la fuerza de gravedad por
el seno de 30 gr Y ustedes se pueden eh
acordar que el seno de 30 gr es igual a
un
1/2 lo que nos queda que esto es igual a
la fuerza de gravedad entre dos la
fuerza de gravedad la calculamos como
New Entonces nos quedan 50 New Y esto es
fp Aunque bueno esta nomenclatura no es
muy correcta esta p también se puede
confundir con perpendicular Pero bueno
Recuerden que en este caso estamos
hablando de que es paralelo Okay el
componente de la gravedad que va
paralelo al plano es de 50 n Cuál será
la aceleración en esta dirección tenemos
que entonces la
fuerza es igual a 50 n y quiero saber la
aceleración bueno usamos nuestra fórmula
ahora Nuestra fuerza perpendicular es
igual a la masa por la aceleración
perpendicular lo que me interesa saber
Es la aceleración la despejo me queda
que la aceleración Perdón no es
perpendicular no me equivoqué paralela
la aceleración paralela a esa superficie
es igual a Nuestra fuerza paralela entre
la masa que con lo que hemos calculado
tenemos que es 50 n ent 10 kg y como
estamos trabajando con las unidades
correctas nos queda que son 5 m por sego
cuadrado aproximadamente la mitad de la
aceleración que esto tendría si lo
dejáramos caer de manera libre porque la
aceleración de la gravedad Es
aproximadamente 10 m cuad y bueno Esto
es la mitad de esta
cantidad en el siguiente videoo vamos a
comenzar a trabajar con la fricción y a
usar esta fuerza normal nos vemos en el
siguiente video